so that so I was in Houston and got some
fears happen first of all I'm in town
and Sunday is a little light you know I
can look at the books and you know why
it is Jo koy is doing a show in a
theater the same time the same town and
it's like that fear of like you know you
know you no matter how long you're in
the business and I love Jo Jost on our
podcast he's like a brother but still
that little thing in the head that goes
what have you done it with your life
look what where he is playing you know
I'm he's playing negative thousands of
seat theaters now he's a big star now as
yeah yeah and so on Sunday night you
know I did three people but 300 people
showed up for my show was just fine
that's pretty good for us for Sunday and
then afterwards I'm out with sandy and I
just want to say I never never never
have done this before but you know when
you do a club the the club provides you
with an emcee a local guy yeah and nine
times out of ten they're just losers I'm
nice to all of them I take them out to
eat you know and I you know we I've
found I try to have fun with it
legitimately the guide this weekend is I
think a guy that I'm gonna know for a
long time I love this kid his name is
Grady Pruitt and he's new he he won
funniest guy in Texas or whatever
he's only been doing comedy for a year
down and he's so good and he's 23 I
think the funniest host I've ever seen
MC for you was that guy Adam Pasi oh
yeah Portland yeah I liked him a lot
he is brilliant he's brilliant he is he
has to make it yeah but no one that
looks like him there's no one that
sounds like him there's no one that
writes like him he is his own guy but I
also want to say that Grady Pruitt drove
me to Walmart at like 2:00 in the
morning he like did the extra that no
matter what I needed
he was there
and he just this Jack Healy you know it
looks like a young Michael Shannon
he has fish eyes yeah yeah weird fish
eyes and he being the carts raining and
he just have googly fish eyes but he was
genuinely a great guy but anyway um my
point is is that we were eating after
Sunday night and my wood and I heard and
then the owner led the manager of the
impro goes hey man I'm at joke boys
after party you got to come they wanted
to come and I was sitting there with a
dilemma
I cannot go I can't just show up to that
thing it would make me feel so I didn't
go but then the worst fear this morning
I was an airport sneaking around and I I
went three hours earlier I want to see
if I could get a first-class ticket
because my fear was my fear was that he
was gonna be flying back at the same
time he was oh my god
no candy do tours around that you had
Scouts oh yeah it'll burn oh yeah fat
birds yeah yeah various yeah I was like
Ferris and I he he's I don't see him
are you sure he's not left that
restaurant over there you know music no
and then all because the coast is clear
yeah and I walked by first cause a bunch
of old white people even I got nervous
you did yeah that was here's the thing I
started with them I could I wouldn't be
able to do it would you not get on the
plane
no I would I wouldn't you just make a
joke don't you make a joke about it just
like power through no there's no joke
there's no joke no I would I mean if I
walk my mouth say yeah you're the king
I'm a peasant that's the only thing I
could say you know and um
congratulations Joe you won that you won
that weekend it was like whole posses in
first class do you know I can openers
he's open
host him out of town yeah oh my god
I like that would be I'll have to go to
therapy you know why is that why am I
like you torture yourself so much
yeah why do i torture myself in this
little paranoia I play these little
games with myself that makes it makes my
life much harder instead of be living
free